[Music]
[Music]
from what i can see you really like
action anime that or rom-coms and it
makes sense i suppose because they're
the two most common genre in the
mainstream sphere it seems but today
we're gonna be looking at the former
this year and the next year have a lot
of promising titles and i'd like to
share some of them with you so something
to look forward to i guess these are i
think of the top 10 most anticipated new
action anime fantasy this 2022 and 2023.
for the sake of keeping the list full of
new titles with potential and remakes
i'll be excluding sequels from this list
but hey before that why don't we look at
this upcoming new fighting game that's
set to take the world by storm
introducing today's sponsor dnf duel dnf
jewel takes your favorite characters
from the much beloved classic dungeon
and fighter franchise and puts them in a
sleek 2.5 d fighting game one of the
most popular and beloved rpg franchises
over a decade ago dungeon and fighter
has been reimagined as a smash style
game complete with 16 awesome characters
that are set to dazzle you with their
amazing skills as with most fighters dnf
duel has the staples a story mode a
survival mode and tutorial modes as well
but we all know the me and the true
appeal of a fighting game is of course
in its pvp mode where technology allows
for seamless matchmaking to pitch you
against the strongest players in the
world in addition to the simple and easy
queuing system dnf dual also features
rollback netcode that will ensure that
game defining things such as lag will
stay the hell out of the way experience
the heart pounding action and the
jaw-dropping attack animations by
purchasing dnf dual now it's now
available for purchase on steam but if
you're a console player the game can
also be played on ps4 and ps5 so what
are you waiting for check out the link
in the description and i'll see you in
the arena
my list begins with reborn to master the
blade
hero king inglis has gotten all he
wanted he's not only a mighty knight but
he's also a ruler of a prosperous empire
being at the top though can get lonely
what meaning is there to life without
thrills without challenges and without
enemies to stand in your way thus he
wishes to live again this time as a
warrior just like how he used to be so
wish granted english finds himself
reborn as a daughter of a minor noble
family thanks to the patron goddess
alistia and now she finds herself in a
pinch due to her status making her
ineligible for knighthood setbacks
challenges adversity all of these are
just obstacles english has to overcome
as she now strives to defeat all that's
in her way and become a new legend a
true noble master of the blade move over
people getting reincarnated from the
real world to a fantasy world reborn to
master the blade takes the reincarnation
premise to a slightly different
direction and adds a dash of gender
bender to it too pretty much the tags
and genres you'd find in web novels that
are picking up steam if you're a fan of
those tropes and tags then this one's
for you this anime comes to us early
next year and i'm looking forward to
seeing this one
objects possessed by spirits thus
granting them a physical form some may
be malevolent some may be kind but one
thing's true members of the sainomi clan
task themselves with peacefully sending
those spirits back to the spirit world
however yorman looks at these spirits
with little to no favor due to his past
and his violent outbursts caused his
grandfather to send him off to live with
bolton a girl who lives with the family
of friendly tsukumogami will yoma manage
to overcome his anger at these spirits
or will he be doomed to live a life of
rage forever this obviously has nothing
to do with the famous monogatari series
but they both deal with supernatural
beings this one subtitled malevolent
spirits does feel more something like
jiu-jitsu kaizen and bleach it is
however a seining title published under
ultra jump the label that brought us
recent jojo titles and the manga
adaptations of some niche modern titles
like no guns life no release date has
been posted as the time of this writing
but it's good to keep an eye on this
title
[Music]
[Applause]
i've always reiterated that video game
adaptations can be hit or miss they
could range from nonsensical to
something that's truly amazing even as a
standalone title recently i've got to
say that i warmed up a lot to them
largely due to the momentum given by
titles like the fake grand order
adaptations princess connect and even
lesser known titles like tact off arc
knights welcome to the party with the
game being a massive success for quite
some time already it's not surprising
that this tower defense would be the
next to join the ever growing line of
gacha game adaptations a game set in the
post apocalyptic planet of terror and
having a cast of cute girls with animal
ears it's no surprise that yo star
picture saw potential in making a
full-blown anime out of this we've
already got a one shot of the anime but
the full tv series is another thing
whether you're a fan of the game itself
or just someone who just loves sci-fi
titles with a lot of waifus the anime
series archanites prelude to dawn will
be for you who knows it could even pull
a princess connect season 2 and end up
being one of the top shows in its season
here's something that could sound
familiar demon swordmaster of excalibur
academy okay tell me if you've heard
this premise before lord of darkness
that was put in stasis awakens after
millennia waking up in the form of a
young man and to a world that has
completely changed through the passage
of time if you're a fan of those then
this is for you demon swordmaster in
contrast takes place in a world where
humanity continues to fight the voids
monsters that have nearly eradicated
humanity awakened after a thousand years
dark lord leonis finds himself safe from
a void by the beautiful rhizealia he
then enrolls in excalibur academy the
last bastion of resistance against the
voids where he looks to both uncover the
events of the past and come to terms
with the modern era the latter is
especially important as it seems that
those monsters have a mysterious
connection to his past it's a premise
that's tried and true but it never
ceases to be awesome i'm very excited
about this show as this is a genre that
i really like who knows if he manages to
pull it off big time in terms of
execution or self-awareness it could
even carve out a niche like misfit of
demon king academy did
up next is chained soldier
[Music]
every once in a while you get these
urban fantasy titles about monsters from
other dimensions and super powered
people fighting them this genre was
pretty big back then with the likes of
shakugan noshana and the persona games
and anime titles so it's nice to see
another one joining their ranks with
chained soldier are lucky or unlucky
depends on how you see it protag is yuki
who finds himself lost in amato an
entrance to a different dimension filled
with unspeakable horrors this time he
gets saved by the badass kyoka however
instead of the usual trope of quickly
integrating the protagonist into her
squad goku has other ideas yeah she'll
work with yuki all right but it's for
her own gain and he'll be joining the
anti-demon corpse as a slave not exactly
the most ideal position but perhaps yuki
is someone who doesn't mind as much
chain soldier if the character designs
don't give it away is the brainchild of
the person who gave us akamega kill very
similar vibes going for it and the same
badass band of female fighters that work
with audience surrogate main character
the setup of character dynamics judging
by the premise seems pretty unique and
it's certainly going to be quite the
different spin on the genre that had its
time in the spotlight a decade ago
ruby finds itself as the next series on
this list
ruby is not a new name the heat animated
series has been going on for quite some
time now and it's popular enough to even
get manga adaptations however as a
full-fledged anime with the style that
we've all come to love well this is a
first however for those who aren't
familiar with the series ruby ice
queendom takes place in remnant a world
fans of the show will be familiar with a
world where people and foreigners live
under the threat of the monstrous grim
facing them are huntresses armed with
their weapons and powers one such group
is team ruby ruby wise blake and yang
all have different backgrounds and
mercurial personalities but they come
together in adventures that put them
against the most dangerous threats the
grim and the extremist group white fang
this is the alternative version of the
series that fans have been waiting for
ice queendom won't be a hard reboot and
it will instead start out being faithful
to the original before setting off to be
its own thing a new adventure that gives
fans a chance to meet new and familiar
faces alike to those who wanted to
experience the story but weren't around
back in the day well now's your chance
to do so in a brand new anime form
and of course mandatory is the guy
reincarnated as a sword is the next
entry
throughout the decade we've seen a lot
of takes on the isakai slash
reincarnation genre we've had the
standard isakai and we've had people
getting reincarnated as all sorts of
things slime spider whatnot well how
about a sword this time finding himself
transformed into a sword in the middle
of a forest the protagonist becomes
instrumental in saving the life of an
injured girl fran turns out fran is not
just any ordinary cacker she is after
all a member of the maltreated black
cats together with the sword who she
named shisho she forms a formidable team
looking to fight for liberation and
justice just when i thought isakayas
were running out of fresh new ideas the
genre proves me wrong yet again from
what i can see this is a story of
adventure and growth but i'm most
excited about the dynamic between fran
and shisho the two unlock each other's
potential in battle but i can also see a
lot of personal growth through their
bond i've not read the novel yet but
with those expectations i feel that this
is going to be one of the upcoming
isakai titles that will garner quite a
nice level of popularity this title
seems to have some potential and will
only have to wait until october to see
if i'm correct or not
[Music]
up next we go old school with ragnar
crimson
ragna crimson takes place in a world
ruled by dragons whether it be the land
sea or sky these creatures of legend
hold dominion and only those who have
surpassed human limits can even hope to
wrest control out of these monsters
hands one such adventurer is the dragon
hunter ragnar with victory as his only
goal he teams up with a mysterious
crimson crimson's motivations are
shrouded with the air of mystery but one
thing is clear the two will stop at
nothing short of victory and the
destruction of the dragon monarchs ragna
crimson looks like one of those old
school traditional style adventure
series perhaps knowing it's published in
enix square manga can answer the
question why ragnar crimson seems to be
one that sticks to a formula but jumps
out with some nice subversions
immediately to keep the series very
interesting to follow the action scenes
are great and the manga has been a nice
read to keep my age for these kinds of
old-school jrpg adventures satisfied
ragna crimson airs this 2023
[Music]
eminence in shadow is the second place
of today's list
a lot of us have had our trunibio phase
remember those good old days where we
just let our imaginations run wild with
no care about what other people thought
or if we'd get laughed at for our
outrageous claims and edgy worlds we'd
cook up in our minds sid gagano is privy
to such machinations wanting to be a
true mastermind a true overlord that
pulls the strings of the shadow
organization that rules the world reborn
in a world of magic he finally finds an
avenue for those plans of his pretending
to be a mob character he starts
recruiting people into his
organization's shadow garden
unfortunately his organization isn't the
only thing present in this world danger
lurks in the shadows as the mysterious
de ebola's cult seems to have found its
way into this world as well it's an
isakai but it's a power fantasy in a
different way instead of sid being the
hero who rises and fights the evil cult
he just wants to live a secluded life
all according to plan before eventually
revealing himself to be the mastermind
of it all it's a good read thanks to the
premise and buoyed by the attractive
girls with their personality dynamics
another light novel staple of course
it's a novel that doesn't take itself
too seriously but why should it be with
that premise if it delivers in the
entertainment department which it does
things will be a-okay
[Music]
finishing up the list is what i think is
the most anticipated non-sequel action
adventure anime of the coming year held
paradise
i've always said that first impressions
make an impact big time and with a title
like that it sure gets the job done gets
people interested gets them wondering
what it's all about a man does hell's
paradise make one great impression from
the get-go the immortal gabi maru the
hollow stands at death's door execution
awaits him yet his body and spirit
refused to let him pass on due to his
resolve to return to his family instead
of a man refusing to die his executioner
instead sees the most powerful asset of
them all thus giving gabi maru a new
purpose he's to join an expedition to an
island believed to be paradise itself
it's here where the elixir of life is
supposed to be found and what better
mercenary to have than someone immortal
with dangers that make the island more
akin to hell gabi maru may have finally
found his match hell's paradise is one
of the top rising stars among shonen
manga it combines a lot of the more
serious action story beats with a high
stakes adventure full of thrills it
promises something quite different from
the usual shonen jump fit of idealistic
teen heroes and powers instead of going
on a much darker route if you want to
know what the buzz is all about there's
only one way to find out watch it
and that's the lot i haven't even talked
about sequels to some of the most
popular action series out there rest
assured the rest of 2022 and 2023 will
be big for fans of action adventure
anime is there any other title that you
have your eyes on make sure that you
tell me in the comment section if you're
interested in videos that are more
catered to a specific series or video
essays you can also check out my other
channel vinichukai for a different
approach on the videos you can also hang
out in the vini tube discord as well as
pay a visit to the channels instagram
and patreon and don't forget to check
out our sponsors game dnf jewel links in
the description it'd be great if you
enjoyed the video i'll continue making
more videos like this and i hope to see
you next time
[Music]
you